what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video titled this is how you stop
your partner from cheating by esther
perel
let me know in the comments what the
best way that you think you could stop
someone from cheating is
and do not forget to hit that subscribe
button you know i'm trying to get to 20
000 subscribers
and each and every one of you helps and
while you're at it bring that
notification
bell okay
this is by esther perrell i watched her
today
and i just think she's interesting so
you're a psychologist and you're a
couple therapist
yes um would these be your typical
clients
no no no no the people who are having
fun
they don't come to the psychologist the
people that come to me
come to me because they're bewildered
because they're in a conflict
because they feel guilty because they
feel shame or because they feel
a torn because they're in love with two
people they on the other side they come
to me because they feel betrayed because
their trust has been shattered because
they wonder
which life they've been living and which
lie they've been living
i think that's the worst part is you
think you're dating someone that's not
actually them um i get the dark side
much more often of this drama
tell me you have you in your book a
state of affairs
yes um you you talk to people all over
the world
about about this topic um modern
relationship and also
infidelity uh
what are the differences between
europe where where we come from and
america
so europe and america i'm belgium yes
and
europe and america europe is i'm gonna
guess
okay just based off what i know i think
cheating
is more like socially accepted in europe
and
it's more like socially accepted to try
to work it out that's my guess
when you're in america it's europe when
you're in europe it's different parts of
europe right
um and and the rest of the world is yet
a whole other story
so i think it's probably important to
say
uh infidelity has existed since marriage
was invented
and so too the taboo against it it
doesn't hurt
any less in sweden than it hurts here
but there may be less of a moral
perspective
it is hurtful not just wrong
it's the difference between wrong and
hurtful and
infidelity is seen as a relational
betrayal so
when i travel the globe i see hundreds
of people who are
affected devastated by this experience
but that's just if you look at the
couple if i ask this
audience here if they've been affected
by the subject in their life
i would guess that 80 of the people will
say they have been affected by
infidelity
in their life and that isn't is that her
husband
because he's given her the googly eye
and it's not just cheated or cheated on
it's the children of it's the friend of
it's the sister the brother of it's
it's the legacy of secrets in families
it's the child of it's a lot of uh
it's a it's a very systemic broad
subject that isn't just a party of two
or three
so so how would you explain i mean how
do you define
infidelity infidelity is actually
very hard to define because the
definition keeps on expanding today
we it's no longer just because you have
a child out of wedlock
you know you had clear proof for most of
history when an affair took place
today is it a chat room is it a massage
with happy ending
and then porn that's another thing do
you guys think porn is cheating yes or
no let me know in the comments
for me personally when i define
something as cheating it's something
that's interactive so
if you're like liking instagram models
pictures and they get the notification
that you're liking like their old
pictures
i would say that's a form of cheating
but when it's not interactive like just
porn i wouldn't i'd say that's like i
don't like it but i wouldn't say that's
cheating is it watching porn
is it uh um is it your dating apps that
you continue to check on
is it talking with your exes that you
have reconnected with on facebook
where do we draw the line is one of the
big questions
about boundaries today and at the same
time they're
very clear markers for understanding
affairs you know and the first and
foremost is the fact that it is
organized around the secret
i mean an affair is not about
non-monogamy it's about a violation
of an agreement of a trust of a contract
so the secrecy is the central element
and then around the secrecy is a certain
level of emotional involvement to one
degree or another
could be hit and run but that too takes
an emotional involvement to make
something matter nothing
and a sexual aura and the sexual aura is
much more important than the idea that
affairs are about sex it's really about
an ira
what do you mean by a sexual order when
you ask people all over the world
that i can tell you if they have been
affected if they've experienced affairs
and and how they experience it the one
word you hear
is that they feel alive affairs
are fundamental acts of transgression in
which people break rules sometimes their
own rules
sometimes their own boundaries that they
have spent years
putting together and the aura means that
you don't need to have
the act of sex you have to have the
energy the erotic energy of aliveness
that comes with the fantasy of this
thing called an affair
so the kiss that you only imagine giving
can be just as powerful as hours of
actual lovemaking
it's about desire it's not about sex and
the desire is about feeling important
feeling seen feeling desired having
someone's attention back on you
feeling that you matter all the stuff
that often gets depleted
inside once committed relationships and
not by fall just of the other
but would you that's really
she verbalized something that i never
realized it's not really necessarily
like
what they do in the affairs that they're
desiring someone else
huh that's interesting i mean couldn't
infidelity then happen
in a happy relationship as well we tend
to think
it goes like this if i find you and
you're my one and only
then i no longer should be interested in
anybody else and especially today
when i have such a paradox of choice and
thousands of people to choose from in
the west
when i finally find the one and only the
one that's going to make me delete my
apps
then i should be free from all of this
and i should have
everything i want with this one and only
therefore if there is an affair
there must be something missing and
either there's something missing
in our relationship or there's something
missing in you
and this symptom model the
my gosh that
wow that's so painful there's something
missing in you advise the true stories
of people because the majority of people
who have affairs are not chronic
philanderers
they are actually often people who have
been faithful for decades
and one day they cross a line that they
never thought they themselves would
cross
and so you want to ask for what and
what starts to happen is this often when
you are
attracted by the gaze of another it
isn't just because you want to leave the
person that you are with
but it is because you want to leave the
person that you have yourself become
and it isn't just that you want to meet
somebody else
but you want to meet another self there
is no greater other than a different
version of yourself
and this goes for men and women do we
do we cheat for the same reason men and
women look
they want to be a better like a
different version of themselves so they
try to find someone else that's going to
fill that that's
really interesting this what i just told
you goes for both
traditionally we have arranged it very
neatly
we have be first of all let's be very
clear men
practically throughout history had a
license to cheat
you know and they had all kinds of
theories that came to justify that they
are
natural roamers you know so we have all
these evolutionary theories and
biological theories to explain why men
are not by nature monogamous whereas
women are these domesticated creatures
we don't know what women would do if
they were given the permission to do the
same
without the consequences that they face
which are very different than the one of
men
that's really interesting and that's
probably why
those rates increase after the
introduction of birth control that's
interesting what we know is that men and
women lie
men lie by exaggerating and by boasting
and by
inflating and women lie by denying and
by minimizing because that is what is
expected from them
culturally worldwide
[Applause]
why oh my gosh that's
so interesting so met
oh my gosh so
men boast and women minimum
i didn't think i would be clapped but
but according to you it hasn't i mean it
doesn't have to be the end of the
relationship
no no i learned that by by working with
so many couples who of course those who
come to me
are not the ones who go to the lawyer so
they come to me because they want to
know is there hope
today in the west most of us are going
to have two or three marriages or adult
relationships
and some of us will do it with the same
person
and so it may mean that this affair
means the end of your first marriage
would you like to have another one
together
and that gave people a dignified way to
understand that you can go through
a big crisis and that some affairs
are breakups but some affairs are
makeups
what do you guys think of this let me
know in the comments some affairs will
ring an alarm
in the relationship about stuff that
people had become complacent about
lazy about neglectful and they realized
well isn't that why they say that like
marriage makes people better because
you're literally
always held accountable to the way that
you act
like long term that they stand too much
to lose and so
they they brace themselves and some
affairs just basically
invite the relationship to say okay this
happened
it's beyond painful let's never minimize
this but there is a way back from there
and actually
it's like in chinese the word crisis
means danger and opportunity
maybe from this we can rise and create
something that may even be
better than what we had so so when when
uh you get the ques you're someone that
says i can't stand it anymore
your advice would be the same as chris
rock yes you can
no i wouldn't say first of all yes you
can that's that's not a therapist's
response
he wouldn't be a good therapist
i i would say i would say you know
what is it that is what is the pain
point for you what is the thing
that you are most upset about i found
that it's not usually being upset it's
like frustration and what is the
bare minimum that you need from your
partner i mean in the aftermath of an
affair it's very clear what you need
from your partner
so she's very solution oriented which
is what i see in a lot of like like
people that have worked in psychology
and therapists
she's not asking like i mean she's
asking what the issues are but she's
really harping on like what would the
solution be the first thing you need
which is the condition by the way for
making it or not
is you need a partner who can
acknowledge how badly they hurt you
if they can't acknowledge that if they
minimize it if they justify it
if they explain that in fact you drove
them to do it you're done
because even if you don't feel guilty
about the experience of the affair
itself
you do have to feel remorse and guilt
about how it hurts the other person that
is a
no a synonym that's a condition
and then from there there is what did it
mean for you
so i've always said today we need a dual
perspective
affairs are about hurt and betrayal but
they are also
about longing and loss and
self-exploration it's
what did you go to look for there why
did this happen to you
how should we behave in our relationship
to not to get betrayed
what is it that you do to make your
partner
feel that they are special that they're
the one you still choose every morning
when you wake up
that they're the one that you want to be
there with
the next morning and the next morning
how do you manifest your love
your appreciation your admiration for
your partner
have you shown up you know you work here
you're very invested in this project
you're super attentive to me
you're charming you're funny when you go
home is this the guy that goes home
or is it the leftovers that you bring
home
[Applause]
damn she called him out damn
the question goes to you too but then
how how do you control your life then uh
by because in life
you don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow that's correct
how do you know with this commitment
that you have met the one that
higher power have placed in i don't
believe in that
conjunction with you i don't believe so
you can meet somebody when you're 16
years old
and marry and say this is going to be my
partner then all of a sudden when you're
44
if something happens what do you do in
this situation i just want to hear
because i'm
i'm a believer and it happened to me you
know
that
i just met somebody and she's sitting
here and it just happened that's why
i don't buy the idea that there is a one
and only
we used to marry till that do us apart
today we marry
till love dies we used to marry and have
sex for the first time
today you marry and you stop having sex
with others
you used to have monogamy one person for
life and today monogamy is one person at
a time
and everybody says i'm monogamous in all
my relationships
and it simplistically makes sense so the
the
norms are changing so fast
there is nothing you can do when you
leave a person then to tell them
how especially if it was not bad then
you
that that you are so sorry that you're
hurting them
and you have loved them deeply and you
wish them the best and you thank them
for everything they've given you
and you wish for them the best and yet
you're going to go
and it is just raw pain you can't
circumvent that
heartbreak is a heartbreak
what about children being do you talk to
the children
of course i talk to them yeah and the
children always lies
so you know but i say
you know and parents usually say the
parents i met
oh the kids are so much happier now oh
yeah that's what you know when
a kid nine years old you have a new dad
a new mother
we you know separated uh married the
neighbor's
wife and then it wasn't their choice
yeah so and and the kids are they're so
much better off well it's interesting
cause i've heard like both sides of that
like i have friends
where their parents stayed together and
they probably shouldn't have and they
wish they got divorced and i also have
friends
whose parents stayed together and
they're glad that they did
even though they like fought a lot when
they were younger tough now they're so
happy
so what are the kids saying that i mean
because we really make a lot of kids and
then we just leave them behind
yes and you make many more children in
sweden than we make in america
but here's the thing we live
in an individualistic culture in the
west
this is not different from us to sweden
and that individualistic culture
has done a few things amongst all the
other things i've just named
it has really brought happiness down
from the heavens
and it has made it a mandate happiness
used to belong for the afterlife you
suffered on earth and then you could be
rewarded afterwards
now we want to be happy and it's not
like we have more desires than your
grandmother had
but we feel much more entitled to pursue
them no it's not for the kids if you ask
the children
unless it's impossible in the house the
children
would rather have their parents stay
together because that's the story that
they're born
into esther i think uh
i think we triggered a few conversations
back in the sofas now
thank you so much that's so interesting
i really i'm gonna binge this lady
expect more of her on my channel
i really like listening to people that
have been in psychology for so long and
like you can really hear
like the ins and outs of like
relationships i don't know it's just
interesting to me
but let me know in the comments if you
agree or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe
to the channel i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers
in june and each and every one of you
help me get to that goal